So I just got my Halloween nails done.
I put these little stars on them
because tonight I'm going to my friend Andrea's birthday.
She's doing it at a magic show,
and it is costume required.
So look at the mood board that she sent us.
This is the vibe for her whole party.
It's, like, mystical, magical.
She's a Halloween baby, and she is a peacock,
just like me. So the girl is going to be dressed to the nine,
so I have to show up.
So I thought these were really appropriate because I'm gonna go as,
like, a sorceress,
kind of mystical witch lady.
Um, I'll show you the costume later,
but it's going to be so much fun.
I haven't been to a magic show since I was 6,
so I have no idea what to expect.
I'm gonna take you along with me
because this is a really cool event to do in Charleston.
I've never heard of it, and I cannot wait to go.